watch dogs latest trailer has been made
with playstation 4 footage but has it
seen a graphical fidelity bump too I'm
mark Walton and this is a game spot news
update following criticism of a previous
watchdog trailer Ubisoft has released a
new welcome to Chicago trailer but the
game's creative director Johnathan Morin
confirming that the trailer was made
wood footage captured from a ps4 dev kit
rather than a high-end PC the trailer
offers up an arguably noticeable bump in
graphical fidelity compared to the
previous trailer morin previously said
of the e3 2012 demo which ran on a
high-end PC that it wasn't a very good
graphics reference while Ubisoft PR
events manager Tessa villain refuted
graphical dan gray claimed by a Twitter
the new trailer shows off the city where
watchdog is set and the physics lighting
weather and other effects watchdog new
graphical engine is capable of however
Morin also said that Ubisoft is still
tweaking the resolution on all platforms
do you think the latest watch dogs
trailer looks better than the old one
should publishers be using footage that
isn't final are you willing to give them
the benefit of the doubt let us know in
the comments below and for more news
keep it games for